like why are we trying to fight like
other social media celebrities i'm
calling out
sitting people in government currently
right now
right the cyclops from texas what's his
name dan crenshaw den
dan crenshaw july 4th me
and you okay
let's do it we'll donate all the money
to freedom financial freedom
for me okay i'm coming dan credshaw
would that be [ __ ] up no why don't we
chart why don't we challenge people in
government 100
let's get a girl to fight aoc taylor uh
we need you
let's get a girl to fight foreign what's
the shorty uh
that could probably beat me up the
rapper oh yeah yeah young man
versus aoc oh bro it's not even just
yeah yeah yeah you just why why why
because i was thinking like a nice
little sexy fight and [ __ ] like that
listen are in the fight it's gonna be
she might have sneak heavies and we
would never talk about no disrespect
you know this is back at all because i
know you rode the shooters
we already have no [ __ ] shootings in
this neighborhood we'll get to that in a
second we couldn't get to work today
everybody
because um there was a murder out new
york is back
it's back today i got to
work early when you think about it
what are you doing i refuse to be late
one more time clap clap
[ __ ] did al show up in his
least threatening outfit possible no he
should have been a gang uniform oh the
guy's literally wearing
paisleys bro like he's got [ __ ] glasses
that's the ged
you're a gd right you know chill out
isn't that a thing
that's the thing gd's
no but al could have been the one who
did the murder
and because of the murder this is the
best part dove's car was parked on the
street that he was trying to sell to
akash right
and akash is trembling about the
decision he's back and forth he don't
know if he's actually doing a little bit
of a see-saw
and all he needed is one reason not to
cut the car and now
akash can't get his new tesla from dove
because it's part of a murder
investigation
i show up in the world you wanna know
the craziest thing that dove doesn't
want to share but i'm gonna show you
sure
all right will you because i ain't gonna
text under 25 miles
in your tesla certain things shut off
like low power mode right right
and dove delivers the car with under 25
miles you know what shuts off
the camera that just films [ __ ] around
the block
so dove could have solved the murder but
we don't snitch here at flagrant
but also i'll snitch
the car snitches that tesla
that tesla stock would really uh
skyrocket that is true
[Music]
nice i'll fight mitt romney mitt romney
not gonna fight you
oh yeah more man oh okay yeah i could do
it but what about what about peter
boulware
what's that what what's that about he
was a professional football player
linebacker in the nfl
uh six foot four two fifth grade
he was good peter b-o-u-l right yeah
played for the ravens
yeah yeah yeah i think he was part of
that historically good defense yeah yeah
yeah so now so now he's involved in
politics he's like is he white or black
he's black he's black as hell
florida state house is a member of the
republican party so uh and he's a
republican
no i ain't playing black republicans bro
they want all the smoke
they're not the least bit worried he's
on the florida board of education so
say what he's on the florida board of
education so no no no i'm not fighting
you
i'm not fighting you we gotta find other
like you know legacy politicians like
womo hey the cnn you're the only
[ __ ] i would fight the what is
it uh chris cuomo
i fight chris cuomo word son i knock out
[Music]
[Applause]
andrew cuomo too but i [ __ ] up chris
cuomo oh no bro he got the body
out of that guy's head are you kidding
me hey ain't no tortellini in that body
brush
yeah no carbs no carbs bro my man is
keto you don't think i [ __ ] up chris
cnn cnn chris cuomo
he's jacked my man so what is jack he
just slapped the [ __ ] up
yo he gonna get that stocked in slap he
would respond too
yo like chris cuomo he's gonna get
[ __ ] up
fight me fight me or your brother killed
mad old people
yo fight me or your brother killed mad
old people simple as that
i mean one of those things already
happened we'll fight and you could
donate the money to the families
of the old people you guys killed
this is who he's getting started with
you is it son
got the [ __ ] guns dog i don't think i
could [ __ ] that's why you live in new
york you don't need no guns
walking around like that what they say
don't need no guns here in new york you
walk around like that yeah you get
[ __ ] up muscles
that's light work you have [ __ ] up
muscles man you was doing a real good
job with wax the other day i was until
he came at me
once he comes at me he's changing [ __ ] a
little bit but i'll [ __ ] him up
bro that's it i'm just saying i can't be
fighting no [ __ ] youtube or tick
tocker you know what i'm saying i need
[ __ ] that are part of the
fabric
why can't you fight a tick tocker yeah
you don't like him anyway he wants
institutional change bro
i want institutional the only people i
will fight
are politicians or
uh media personnel like i i fight
i fight portnoy i want to see that hey
hey hold up hold up hold up i'm saying
stop right there
poor they're gonna have you [ __ ]
donkey hooked like they're [ __ ]
running back
i don't know if that's what you want
i think he's dope i'm not angry at him
you know what i mean like i like what he
does i think he's [ __ ] hilarious so
it'd be tough but
that type of personality would would be
a like money gathering fight
like like for example like tucker
carlson would be the perfect person to
fight
oh but he wouldn't if you're like if
you're some like super liberal dude
like i'm trying to think like who's uh
jon stewart's got to run it back like
jon stewart
bro because they already have the beef
they already have the beef come on son
that'll be good that'll be good that's
what i'm saying yeah we gotta get into
fight promotion
you